it will be a relief to small businesses
particularly the hospitality industry
pubs restaurants and so on that have
been struggling to staff
shifts because so many uh people are
being told to
isolate but the latest figures show that
uh there were
almost 396 000 pings in the week to last
wednesday
and that compares to 689
000 in the previous seven days that is
a fall of 43 now some of that may be due
to
people uh switching off the contact
tracing
uh element of the app we know that some
businesses
have businesses have been encouraging
staff to do that to avoid being pinged
but there is separate data from nhs test
and tracers also come out today for the
same week
and that shows that there were 406 000
people who have contacted
been told to isolate because they had
been
close to somebody who was known to have
tested positive
that is down 32 over the week
and that does suggest that perhaps the
two things together
may be related to uh the drop in
reported cases that we are currently
seeing
uh on the government dashboard but it
will be welcomed by
businesses as i say they won't mind what
the reason is
but if they can staff those [ __ ] uh
shifts and and start
uh trying to uh to make some profit
after so long
uh of not being able to to work in the
economy that will be welcome